翻訳: Natsuki NAKAMURA
校正: Kyoko Kamura
みなさん こんにちは
竹下友里絵と申します
生まれも育ちも神戸でして
両親や祖父母も会社員
農業などの一次産業からは
遠い場所で生活してきました
そんな私は今「タベモノガタリ」という
団体を立ち上げ
大学に通いながら
食の分野で起業準備中です
今日はそんな私が大切にしている
トピックの１つ
フードロスについて
お話ししたいと思います
私がフードロスに問題意識を
持ち始めたのは ７年前
高校２年生のときに１年間行った
カナダの留学がきっかけでした
そこではカナディアンファミリーの家で
ホームステイをしていました
当時まだ若い夫婦と
中学校２年生のホストシスターと
小学校２年生のホストブラザー
晩御飯はだいたい肉をカチカチに焼くか
茹でたパスタに粉チーズをかけるだけか
買ってきたピザか
そんな生活を送っていました
ある日の晩御飯
いつものようにホストシスターと
ご飯を食べていました
すると彼女は
「もうお腹いっぱいだよ」と言って
まだプレートにたくさん
パスタが残っているのに
それをキッチンの方に持っていきました
私は何の気もなしに
その様子を見ていたわけです
冷蔵庫に入れて
次の日食べるんかなって
すると彼女は なんの躊躇もなく
それをゴミ箱に捨てました
幼い頃から 米粒１粒残さずに
食べるんだよって
教わってきた私にとって
その光景はすごく衝撃的でした
きっとそれは 彼女と私の食の違いから
生まれたんだなという風に
思っています
そこから私は
世界の一方ではこんなにたくさん
食べ物が捨てられているのに
でも世界のもう一方では
食べられずに死んでいる人がいる
そんな世界全体の食のアンバランスに
問題意識を持ち始めます
そこから 世界人口が
毎日 ”おいしい” で満たされた世界
そんな世界の実現を目指して
活動を始めました
最初は関西学院大学
総合政策学部に通います
それは 国際協力という側面から
飢餓問題にアプローチするためでした
しかし 大学３年生になって
私はもっと食に向き合わないと
いけないという風に思い
神戸大学の農学部に編入します
そこで学んだのは 主に農業を
メインとして食を作る大変さ
そういうのを身をもって
実感しました
大学４年目は休学して 上京して
急速冷凍機の販売商社のベンチャーで
インターンシップをします
そこまで私は フードロスというと
消費者が出しているものだと思っていたんです
けれど この会社は
冷凍技術を用いて
流通段階だったり 生産段階のロスを
無くすような取り組みをされていました
例えば 北海道で
１日何万トンもとれるイワシ
イワシっていうのは凄い傷つきやすくて
鮮度の劣化が早いです
なので 漁獲量の多くは
油にされてしまっていました
しかし冷凍技術を
導入することによって
年がら年中 魚として消費者の方に
届けられるようになりました
消費者段階だけじゃなくて
仕組みによって
生産段階や物流段階のロスを
なくせるということに 私は気づきます
私がカナダで感じた
食べ物が捨てられているっていう現状
その時 日本はそんなに捨てていないだろう
という風に思ったんです
だって 私たちは
ものを大切するというか
もったいないという
精神をもっているから
しかし そんな日本のフードロスは
年間 約640万トンです
世界の食糧援助量の約２倍に値します
フードロスが出ている段階や
原因は様々です
私が今取り組んでいるのは
生産段階と消費段階です
少し具体的な話をしましょう
私は生産段階のキーワードは
「自然のブレ」
消費段階のキーワードは
「食への愛着」だと思っています
ではまず 生産段階の方からです
生産段階で発生している
ロスの原因は大きく２つです
労働力不足によって収穫しきれずに
そのまま落ちてしまうものと
規格という枠組みによって
そもそも流通に出せないもの
私はこの時 ある１つの問いに
ぶつかりました
「規格」って何だよって
誰が作ったんだよって
流通の効率化のために
農産物の形が決められたりとか
消費者が土がついていない
形の綺麗なものを求めたりとか
作ったのは生産者ではなく
食べる人や 運ぶ人だったんです
ここまで規格、規格という
話をしてきましたが
私はこの枠組みを
無くしていきたいと思っています
じゃあ そのためにどうするか
それは 贈答用などに使われるような
形の美しいものと
少し糖度が落ちてしまって
傷がついているものを
一緒に扱うということではなく
いわゆるＢ級と言われているものに対して
「加工用」という明確な用途を
見つけてあげることが
必要なのではないかと思います
そこで私が始めたのが
加工用果物流通事業
「ミニナルミ」でした
例えば 桃
Ａ級と言われるものは
形がきれいで 糖度がのっていて
重量もしっかりあるものです
いわゆるＢ級と呼ばれるものは
例えば 雨がたくさん降って
桃に水分がたくさん吸収されてしまって
糖度が落ちてしまったもの
あるいは 実が小さくて
重量そのものが足りないようなもの
それらは生で食べるには
甘みを感じにくく
おいしく食べることができません
しかし ジャムなどに
加工することによって
桃の食感や風味を活かしながら
おいしく食べることができます
果物の出来具合に対して
適切な使用用途を見つけてあげること
それが「規格外」というものを無くすために
必要なのではないかと思ったのです
農産物は自然からの贈り物です
そんな自然のブレを楽しめる人が
増えたらいいなと思っています
例えば「土がついているってことは
これは朝採ってくれたのかな」とか
「虫が食ってるってことは
農薬少なめで作ってくれたのかな」とか
そういった自然のブレを
楽しめるような人が増えたら
規格という枠組みは どんどん
広がっていくと思うのです
次に消費段階の話をしましょう
消費段階のロス
いわゆる食べ残しだったり
家庭で冷蔵庫の中で眠ったまま
捨てられてしまうような食材
それらが発生している原因は
私は食への愛着への薄れから
来ているのではないかと思っています
ものを捨てるというのは
食材に限った話だけではなく
愛着があれば
捨てないと思うんです
たとえば 写真やアルバム
あれらはただの紙切れ一枚です
でもその紙切れ一枚に数えられないほどの
物語や愛が込められているから
私たちは捨てることができません
では 皆さんが普段食べているものに
愛を感じているでしょうか？
多くの人の答えは
「No」だと思います
コンビニやスーパーなど
工業製品化されていったり
あるいは 作り手との距離が
どんどん遠くなってきていたり
昔はそうではなかったです
例えば 近くのおじいちゃんが作ってくれた
きゅうりっていうのが分かるから
じゃあ 全部残さず食べよう
美味しく食べよう っていう風に
思うことができました
けれど今は作っている人の
顔も見えません
想いも見えません
なので 私たち食べる人は
食べ物から愛を感じることが
難しくなってきています
それによって何が起きるか
例えばおにぎり１つを
捨てるってなった時に
米粒の塊を捨てているというより
どちらかというと 100円玉を
捨てているような感覚に近いかもしれない
食べ物を捨てることが
簡単になってきています
だから私は消費者の方に
食べ物を届ける時
その食べ物の背景にある物語や
農家の想いを伝えることを大事にしています
これは〇〇さんが作った桃でね
こういうこだわりポイントがあってね
こういう風に食べてくださいって
すると タベモノガタリの
リピーターさんは
「今度は〇〇さんとこの葡萄を売ってるって
聞いたんだよ 買いに来たよ」って
少しずつ食品への愛を
感じてくれているのではないかと思います
これらの問題は
フードロスのみならず
我々のライフスタイルにも
影響を与え始めています
食べ物に込められた愛を
感じにくくなっているから
消費者はどんどん食のことを
考えなくなっています
私はそれを 食への諦めだと
思っています
誰かが工業的に作ってくれた食を
何も考えずに選択していませんか
体を作っている食で もしかしたら
命に関わるかもしれないのに
自分が何を食べているか分からずに
食を選択している人は
実は多いのかもしれません
私がフードロスや
食産業という領域に向き合う時
仕組みと意識の両側面からの
解決を目指しています
仕組みが変わったとしても
消費者の食の選択が変わらなければ
何も意味がない
逆に 消費者の食の選択が変わったとしても
仕組みが変わっていなければ
消費者は自由な食の選択を
することはできません
例えば 曲がったきゅうりを運ぶ
物流の仕組みが整ったとします
でも 消費者が「曲がったきゅうりは
ちょっと買わないよ」って
なったとしたら
きっとスーパーに曲がったきゅうりが
並ぶ事はないでしょう
反対に 消費者が
「曲がったきゅうりでも買うよ」
「真っ直ぐなやつと同じ値段で
買うよ」と言ったとしても
曲がったきゅうりを運ぶ
物流の仕組みが整っていなければ
それもまた スーパーに曲がった
きゅうりが並ぶことはありません
日本のフードロスを無くすためには
また 一次産業を強くするためには
仕組みと意識の両側面からの
解決が必要です
フードロスという問題を解決するのは
非常にシンプルだと思うんです
作った食べ物を 必要としている人全てに
届けることができると思うんです
私は そんな社会の実現を目指して
これからも頑張りますし
みなさんも
一（いち）食の消費者として
一緒にそんな社会を
目指していきませんか？
ご静聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）
ありがとうございます